Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Our endeavors in creating amazingly detailed
fluid simulations is often hamstrung by the
fact that we need to simulate the motion of
tens of millions of particles. Needless to
say this means excruciatingly long computation
times and large memory consumption.
This piece of work tries to alleviate the
problem by confining the usage of particles
to a narrow band close to the liquid surface
and thus, decimating the number of particles
used in the simulation. The rest of the simulation
is computed on a very coarse grid, where we
compute quantities of the fluid like velocity
and pressure in gridpoints, and instead of
computing them everywhere, we try to guess
what is happening between these gridpoints.
The drawback of this is that we may miss a
lot of details because of that. And the brilliant
part of this new technique is that we only
use a cheap, sparse grid where there is not
a lot of things happening, and use the expensive
particles only near the surface, where there
are a lot of details we can capture well.
The FLIP term that you see in the video means
Fluid Implicit Particle, a popular way of
simulating fluids that uses both grids and
particles.
In this scene, the old method uses 24 million
particles, while the new technique uses only
one million, and creates closely matching
results. You can see a lot of excess particles
in the footage with the classical simulation
technique, and the foamish-looking version
is the proposed new, more efficient algorithm.
Creating such a technique is anything but
trivial. Unless special measures are taken,
the simulation may have robustness issues,
which means that there are situations where
it does not produce a sensible result.
This is demonstrated in a few examples where
with the naive version of the technique, a
piece of fluid never ever comes to rest, or
it may exhibit behaviors that are clearly
unstable.
It also takes approximately half as much time
to run the simulation, and uses half as much
memory, which is such a huge relief for visual
effects artists.
I don't know about you Fellow Scholars, but
I see a flood of amazing fluid papers coming
in the near future and I'm having quite a
bit of trouble containing my excitement. Exciting
times are ahead indeed.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!